obviously with with hob not being here
anymore um you know that that's going to
open up things for for for everybody you
know he he had a lot of targets and then
so those targets got to be filled up
with with other guys so um
you know we're all going to be able to
get it done and i feel like it's gonna
be a great season
will fuller texans receiver who can be
very very effective when healthy and
they're hoping that he will be this year
look at the moves for this franchise and
the biggest name on there deandre
hopkins gone traded to the arizona
cardinals one of the realities he wants
to be paid like julio jones and the
texans aren't willing to do that
especially with deshaun watson on deck
for a major contract so deandre hopkins
out chris
texans you know just kind of have that
weird sense of they overachieved last
year to win the division they finally
found a way to win a playoff game they
had the chiefs on the ropes in the
divisional round up 24 nothing in the
first half but you did you know and
deshawn watson you and i are both
believers but is there enough around
desean watson especially now that
deandre hopkins is gone i i think
there definitely is i don't worry about
houston's offense i don't when i sit
here and just look at it and i know it's
on paper and everything like that you
know again you're right it seems like
it's a team that consistency is not
always its strength but yet we keep
looking up and going up they're in the
playoffs up they're ten and six up
they're 11 and five i mean and that it
partly is because hey billy o'brien he's
a tough sob and then you got a
quarterback who's a superstar i mean a
superstar i mean he really is he is
special you know we'd be making a much
bigger deal about him if it weren't for
patrick mahomes in kansas city but
you've heard me say this and i think in
a lot of ways
without deandre hopkins with the houston
texans can be a blessing for this
offense because i do think it could be a
little bit more offense by committee
instead of what we saw so many times
last year and i know we showed some
clips where we just went hey it's third
down this team knows they're throwing
the deandre hopkins this is what they do
it's it was you know it was almost it
was a tell-tale sign
now
man brandon cooks fuller randall cobb
who does what they're interchangeable in
that new england offense they can all do
a little bit of everything and if will
fuller can stay healthy and be that down
the field guy with one of the best down
the field throwers in the game
their offense i think is going to have
to carry you know the team a little bit
but i think the offense could be
actually more special especially because
they've got an offensive line finally
rounded into shape and david johnson
we'll see what he's got but if he's got
something and can be back to the guy we
once saw i go damn this offense is gonna
be one of the five best in the league
because these are some pretty damn good
talented receivers running backs and of
course the quarterback's a superstar
remember the texans colts game where you
know they shut him down what was it a
fourth down play that's what i'm talking
about
right darius leonard after the game said
we knew we knew to go after deandre
hopkins that's that's who they have
that's what they have that's who they're
going to treat kansas city
remember that the regular season game it
was the same thing it was a fourth down
at the end of the game to your point and
it was exactly the same thing it was
watson got the ball oh wait deandre
hopkins i'm supposed to throw to him
he's not open and it ends up in
completion and the game was over so
thank you for verifying my point is what
i'm saying
you're taking away the crutch if you
trade deandre hopkins you're taking away
the quarterback's crutch and you're
forcing him to diversify his looks yeah
passing game and that may look this may
be a key ingredient i i still i can't
believe i'm getting behind the idea that
the texans are better off with on
without deandre hopkins because i don't
think they are i hear you but you can
see the logic
right the next level in the development
of desean watson
is to get him to throw it to the open
guy not to the guy right and he throws
it to the guy and he waits too long
chris to your point that you make all
the time desean watson treats too many
plays like they're the last player of
the super bowl and he extends and he
extends and he extends why because he's
waiting for de'andre hopkins to get open
there's no that's what it yep there is
there's no doubt or he's a little greedy
at times looking for a big play and you
just go man deshawn just you got a five
yard completion throw it there and then
you won't have to make some unbelievable
play where yeah you might make it you
might not but of course we've seen him
take a beating doing that type of stuff
too and i
i love the guy i mean he's one of my
favorite players to watch in the league
and one of my favorite people you know
to hear interviews from and everything
like that to where you know i know we've
had a lot of conversations about that
don't take those car crash hits i don't
want any more car rides in jacksonville
with a punctured lung so you got to go
play a football game and that type of
stuff i mean he's a special competitor
so the offense you know that's my logic
mike you you explained it really well i
think in the development of desean
watson it might go a long way for him
not to have deandre hopkins there it's
gonna force him to see the offense and
the picture of the play in totality more
instead of like oh i just trust this guy
let me go to him me and him make it
happen all the time and i'm going to go
back to that well and i just don't know
if that's that's not enough to carry
your team i don't think into a super
bowl or anything like that you know
mahomes oh wait you got tyrek hill okay
i got sandy watkins and kelsey and
running backs and i'll spread the ball
to them that's fine you do that you know
i want to see that from watson now to go
to that that next guy the next group of
guys spread it spread it out spread it
all around
and let me just say this real quickly
last hour we were talking about the
browns and i said maybe baker mayfield
needs to shed the saltiness when it
comes to things that he may not like
that people in the media say and i
mentioned mahomes and lamar jackson and
calamari
i mean nothing bothers desean watson no
he's got the perfect quarterback
demeanor you can say anything you can do
anything and he's just going to go to
the next play and that's the
part of this that could make the deandre
hopkins trade work he's not going to sit
around and mope right and sulk and pout
over the fact that deandre hopkins is
gone even though he clearly wasn't
thrilled about it when it happened now
you move on to david johnson at running
back will fuller brandon cooks arriving
via trade with the rams randall cobb
free agent signing kenny stills still
there part of the trade that that they
did with the dolphins last year you know
if those guys are healthy and that may
be a big if especially with fuller and
we love fuller as a player but you got
to be on the field in order to play and
and play well if those guys are healthy
those five johnson and those four
receivers are healthy
that that gives desean watson plenty of
options chris oh it definitely does uh
it i mean you know it's an offense again
it's new england we know and they know
how to spread the ball around and do
different things and we haven't seen
that from houston and i think that'll be
big and listen the other aspect of this
we they they need to be that way i think
you know
the one thing we lose i think one of the
reasons we're a little bit like what are
the texans and you know
you know how good are they you know the
defense stunk last year there's no other
way to put it
you know and and of course they lost one
of their best defense alignment and dj
reader to free agency so they need some
of these guys in the secondary some of
these young guys some of these guys in
vernon hargraves who they got from tampa
last year and gary and connolly who they
traded from the raiders they got to show
up and play better too
but you know j.j watt still real good
you know but there's not a lot of
household names on that front seven that
people are gonna know and the run game
and pass game last year they were bad in
both areas especially the pass game and
they might have to work some of those
kinks out early in the year and that's
where they're gonna have to rely on this
offense in watson at least maybe until
that group comes along and can hold you
know hold their own
underscoring your point about the
defensive struggles you're up 24-0 right
in the first half of a playoff game and
still give up 51. i mean think about it
you're spotted 24
and you're up
and your defense still has an epic
collapse and gives up more than 50
points to the kansas city chiefs you
know i
i just wonder what kind of a scar that
leaves on this team we asked peter king
about that yesterday
um because he he did his latest football
morning in america focusing on a day in
the life of the texans training camp i
mean not only was that the last game you
played it's the next game you play how
do you get this team ready to go back
into that same environment minus the
fans yeah uh and and face that same team
how do you change that outcome chris how
do you come out of there with a better
result um and and if you get up by 10 17
24 points
when do you start bracing for the
onslaught from the chiefs well you know
those are real questions no doubt
and i think the one thing that's going
to motivate them continually here
throughout you know training camp and
going up to this game is that bill
o'brien's gonna they're gonna still be
watching that film and i it's gonna be a
fear motivation i think where they're
gonna look at it and go damn if we don't
change some things up and play better
we're going to get run out of the gym by
my homes and company once again so that
is a very real aspect i mean fear is one
of the greatest motivators there is and
you know that that's that's going to be
interesting to watch no doubt about it
mike you know and then again we go into
it because i i like doing this you look
at their early season schedule
great scots batman i mean whoa
at chiefs ravens at steelers vikings
that is a tough four and then you know
in that division as we know the nfafc
south so competitive you start out one
and three something like that i think
this year in the afc south where you
know there's stability with the
tennessee and the colts and phillip
rivers being there now and everything
like that
man i i don't know if you'll be able to
climb out of that hole uh in that
division this year
the good news is the texans went to
kansas city last year during the season
and won
31-24 yeah you know if you're bill
o'brien how do you balance
what film you show how much of the film
from the regular season win how much of
the film from the playoff loss as you
try to get these guys ready you try to
get these guys to the point where
they're not intimidated by this chiefs
team because we have gone on in there
and beaten them yeah
they'll have they'll be able to lean on
that now i do i think they had a
shamrock and uh rabbit's foot up their
butt that day yes i do you know they
were up 17 to nothing if you remember
that was that game where my homes like
through the deep pass down the field and
they're going to get past interference
and it's going to be down at the one
yard line and they overturned it
uh and it saved the texans it really did
so you know it'll be interesting and i'm
interested in this houston texas team i
mean listen worst case best case what do
you see mike i don't know i mean they're
another team i look at and go i'm not
shocked if they win the division they
could go 11 and 5 and 12 and 4. i
wouldn't be shocked by that but i don't
know i could go seven and nine they
could go seven and nine i think that's
about this that's the floor i see i
can't even give them six and ten desean
watson ain't going six and ten that
ain't happening he's too good so seven
and nine and i think that would even
take like some wheels to fall off i
almost want to say eight and eight is
like as bad as it can get but i'll go
seven and nine for worst absolute worst
case scenario
the team they beat in the wild card
round made it wait a minute the team
they they beat to get to the division
not in the wild card round because they
wouldn't have made it to the afc
championship game if they lost in the
wild card round duh the titans who
finished second in the division made it
to the afc championship game the colts
have reloaded with philip rivers i mean
this is a tough division the jaguars are
the only team that people are writing
off right and they may be a team that
you know they get lucky under gardner
minshew and it all falls together so
it's gonna be a tough year for the
texans a defending champion a two-time
defending division champion that we just
are kind of looking at saying do we
really think they can win that division
i'm not sure but i agree with you best
case they win the division best case
maybe they get to the afc championship
game
worst case they they tumble and they
fall out of the the playoff chase all
together but uh but we both feel
strongly about deshaun watson they're
going to be in the conversation for as
long as watson is on the team and maybe
before the start of the season we'll
find out that watson has the long-term
contract that will ensure his future as
the quarterback of the houston texans
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports